uh okay let's start it up rogan thoughts
boys
this is heavy now i know it looks like
we just got as many black people in this
room as we possibly could
in order to have the discussion but tell
the people you guys were booked here a
month ago to come here facts 100
and also when i walked into the studio
it's just white people so say again i
appreciate that we waited for alex yeah
appreciation yeah yeah yeah
you know what it is
let's go
let's go
it's because white people are on time
yeah okay maybe there's something over
there the timing of it is facts for
february they hold up them old clips
just in time for history month yeah yeah
shout out to them no but i don't know
you know when some [ __ ] is calculated
when it feels calculated it feels
calculated it i do you guys think that's
what it is
to me it's pretty obvious but i'm
curious when you would if you've never
watched the podcast and you've never
seen the clips where they've been pulled
from yeah
i i you would 100 think he's one of the
worst part people
undoubtedly right i've been watching the
podcast for what 13 12 years now so i'd
even see the original planet of the apes
clip when it first like when it was out
right like that's old that you're
talking about that's when he had like
the three man set up and it looks
terrible
yeah but that's when podcast was wasn't
taken off yeah so do i think it's
calculated undoubtedly just by the way
they cut it up some of the some of the
cuts were nefarious
like even when he's talking about like
yo the word has a lot of meaning he
would say the word instead of saying the
n word right are we going to act
are we going to sit here and act like
somebody just discussing a difficult
topic is the same as going up to
somebody saying hey you're it you know
what i mean right right right i think we
all there's a huge difference if i'm
going to history class and say the word
right in a history context where i
wouldn't look at him like he said the
word how dare this right all know
there's a difference
and anybody who's reasonable know so
when they edit that and they cut it and
they do a super cut like that i can't
help but look at you funny right just by
the way the video came out yeah right
right yeah that makes sense like are you
saying there's a difference between
calling somebody that yeah and then
saying the word in a discussion the
difference between yo you're a [ __ ] and
me saying man listen the way the word
[ __ ] has been used throughout history
there's a difference between those two
things offensive just because you said
the word technically that's what it is
but that's where we're at now and i
believe that there was a switch like
let's
can we just stop two seconds
let's agree that there's been a switch
in the past
two years
or three there's been a switch of how we
handle things right
with that word that word was everywhere
now we handled it and everything and
stuff same thing that happened with
that's the
blackface in canada but that that's
another situation but
there's been a switch where people get
really robbed up so that's what's
happened within
three years
but you're going to take a clip from
before that's what's interesting
looking at the situation as like
you're taking something from let's say
10 years ago but you're judging it with
the eyes of how we think now
not taking the conservation there's been
a switch in the past three or five years
after five years even with the
trans stuff and everything's like
there's been a switch right right right
from 15 or 10 years ago and judging it
at the eyes of today i i feel like it's
a bit dissension noise let's put
everything in context and we have to put
everything in context with the time the
the the the the time that it's
that happens it's been watched yeah
interesting al what do you think i agree
with that this version
to me it's like when
people are going back on old tweets and
trying to cancel people so now that
everybody wiped their twitter now they
don't know what youtube oh [ __ ]
yeah everything every day i go on my
facebook and i remove my memes that i
put before
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like i got some some strikes on facebook
something i posted on in 2012 right
you didn't catch it in 2012 when i
posted it yeah the rules probably
changed over time too so to judge
backwards is so nonsensical but the
platform won't take that on themselves
they don't say they don't want it to be
their liability so they put it on you to
go review everything you've ever done
with the new rules that come out but
let's keep it a stack who the [ __ ] is
reading terms of service right right
everybody just scrolls down and hits
accept you know i mean when you sign up
for anything i don't think anybody's
ever read terms of service in the whole
life yeah no so i was just like
and you know what i can't say i don't
know if you felt the same way when i saw
all those black celebrities whether it's
india rv or all of them on the page
being like yeah go queen [ __ ] rogan i
can't believe
i get upset because i'm like i hate the
way sometimes black folks can be so
manipulated to whatever agenda somebody
else has to use like the racism term to
bring down like if spotify or whoever's
got problems with this misinformation
want to deal with that fine but don't be
trying to rope in like he's a misogynist
oh he's a racist uh he's a trans they
always go through the same yeah to try
to get you yeah and then i just can't
stand it with black celebrities just
jump on so readily for something they
don't know [ __ ] about yeah i understand
the knee-jerk reaction right because if
it's something that you've experienced
that's painful and you're not familiar
with that person and you like you said
earlier you just see the video the
knee-jerk reaction is like nah [ __ ] this
this is crazy if you don't know that
person but i think that like there's two
discussions happening and there's a
little confusion one is when when people
like myself are out here like defending
rogan now that's my guy i just defend my
friends you don't even have to ask me
why like i know this person like simple
as that if al does some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
al didn't do nothing yeah you don't care
that's not his own with a machete
machete and you know you've also chopped
down sugar cane and you're chopping
through bone you're like oh this is like
sugar cane like if you're that type of
person like it doesn't matter you're my
god who cares yes you can trust me
because i know what you do
we have to trust you preacher we have to
trust you and there's no policy
yeah i want to show you my property in
port-au-prince i can see
no it so that
there were people responding they
clearly don't know joe that they were
saying like oh all these people out here
trying to justify him saying the n word
and him saying this this uh you know
horrible joke and it's like joe has said
that he thinks those things are horrible
himself so nobody's trying to defend
something that joe doesn't think is okay
what we're trying to defend is
the accusation of him being a racist and
we know this person as a friend so we're
like nah he's not i know this person's
friend and also we're trying to talk
about the convenience and timing yeah of
this uh racist accusation because they
tried to hit him with the misinformation
that didn't stick because he put it
right back in their face right so all of
a sudden this race like immediately
right off the bat comes out this has
been out for 10 years everybody a lot of
people who are tweeting about this video
seen that video bro yeah a lot of them
see it and didn't say [ __ ] and they
piled the [ __ ] on right when it was
convenient so that's what i'm talking
about like this is a hit piece and i
don't know who the [ __ ] started it and
now that there's so much pylon
you can't right really point in any one
direction right but it does come from
somebody
and i'm like who benefits the most from
this i don't know the next video is
going to be the trans video yeah it's
going to be yeah and the final blow is
going to be anti-semitic yeah
[Music]
that's the one i'll give them a pass
here first
yeah that's the one you can't
yeah
i mean
you know who's going through this um
right now it's jimmy carr
you know comedian jimmy carter yeah did
you see the joke that he's getting no no
i heard about it so basically he had
this joke in his special where uh and
i'm gonna probably butcher the joke but
he essentially goes uh you know we've
all heard about the absolute atrocities
that happened during the holocaust where
six million jews uh we know were killed
uh um but a lot of people don't talk
about uh is the
thousands of roman gypsies that were
also killed and that's because people
don't ever highlight the good things
[Laughter]
i'll be laughing like he had a
have you ever been to europe and you
know how they feel about gypsies you
know every europeans are laughing they
[ __ ] yes the european viewers are
like yeah we hate them [ __ ] too
bro i think i think a gypsy baby woke up
and laughed at it
a sleeping gypsy baby woke up giggled
went back to bed
but uh but here's here's a perfect and
like they're trying to get him out of
here for that yeah yeah and yeah i guess
i don't know why
he has the the benefit of having an
audience
yes he said it on a comedy special where
there's a group of people that all
laughed and so when people look at it
they go oh yeah there's a buffer he's
trying to be offensive he's trying to
tell an offensive joke yes so there's a
little bit more like context and i think
social groups and we've had this
conversation before it's like rarely do
people get cancelled for jokes yeah like
when it is a true no no like a true joke
you know like your boy mike ward was
making a joke and he's but that's and
and the little kid is back on that [ __ ]
again really so now supreme court
just give context real quick give
context uh my acquired he's looking at
quebec comedian and he
um he made a joke
13 years ago yep he wrote that joke 13
years ago made that joking special about
a kid and basically the the the the
the whole thing is about the whole joke
the premise of the joke is how you
there's some people that are untouchable
that you can talk you cannot talk about
different people and he put that kid in
there that kid has a disability all
right and
uh that kid tried to sue him
for 40 grand or something first it was
80.
then it was 35 and then supreme court of
canada said like nah
he didn't infringe in your rights it's
comedy chill
kid is back wow
for 372 thousand dollars whoa
for him and his mom
and now they want to go on defamation
wow
because
yeah i try to drown the kid the kid
won't die i thought that this disability
was that
uh
he was uh
i thought whatever yeah basically his
ability is that he's ugly as well you
just took a machete to that [ __ ] joke
and i sat down
at the end of the day at the end of the
day
what i could do with a machete right
you remember that bit right there you go
so vividly
at the end of the day
at the end of the day when you're seeing
all this stuff i don't i don't think
it's necessarily more so about the jokes
because i don't think it matters whether
you're joking or not it doesn't really
matter to them i think it's what you
represent
and then how big of a figure you are
right because
carr as big as he is he's also living in
england and england they don't really
[ __ ] with cancer culture the same way
that we do out here so it doesn't matter
nearly as much there maybe it's
chappelle for what he says is his comedy
specials whether you deem it a joke or
not i think once you start to represent
something in the zeitgeist they start to
look at you differently
you